[Music]
on this Thursday night two Edmonton
Police constables murdered
the latest Canadian officers to be
killed in the line of duty their lives
and sacrifice will not be forgotten what
happened and what we know about the
gunman
is the clock ticking for tick tock
this is threatening to ban the app
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with the loss of two police
officers in Edmonton they were shot and
killed early this morning while
responding to a call about a family
dispute police say 30-year-old Constable
Brett Ryan and 35 year old Constable
Travis Jordan were shot before they
could even draw their weapons police
sources say the suspect is 16 or 17
years old he is also dead his mother is
in the hospital Heather York's West has
our top story on the officers killed in
the line of duty
all morning the line of officers
continued to grow
standing at attention outside Edmonton's
medical examiner's office their hearts
heavy today the Edmonton Police Service
has
been marked by a really an unthinkable
and a horrific tragedy as two of our
members have died in the line of duty
Constable Brett Ryan a five and a half
year veteran with the Edmonton Police
Service and Constable Travis Jordan with
the service for eight and a half years
we're responding to a domestic violence
call shortly after 12 30 a.m upon
arrival the two Patrol members went
inside the building approached the suite
and were shot by a male subject
according to Chief Dale McPhee neither
of the two constables had been able to
return fire fellow officers on scene
took the two men to hospital and though
they tried they were unable to save
their colleagues lives as a former
police officer myself this hits very
close to home so
told my brothers and sisters out there
my heart is with you the suspect a
teenage boy later died from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound the teen's
mother is now in hospital with injuries
so severe she is still fighting for her
life for residents of the North Edmonton
apartment complex the news has come as a
shock there's families here there's
children all summer long there's
children playing out front there's
people sitting on their in their
backyards
it's this is just our home every day
families of the police officers send
their loved ones off to duty to work and
hope they return home safely
this did not happen today tributes are
now pouring in as people remember these
two young men one memory viewers Might
Recall Constable Travis Jordan went
viral three years ago for an act of
kindness as a snow angel instead of
giving a woman a ticket for having a car
window covered in snow he helped her out
and gave her a snow brush Donna such a
lovely memory Heather York's West in
Edmonton thank you
four other Edmonton police officers have
been killed in the line of duty since
1918 and across Canada in the past six
months seven police officers have died
on the job in December Constable Greg
per shallow was fatally shot in an
ambush in Ontario Constable Shaylin Yang
died in October in BC she was stabbed
while assisting a Parks officer in
serving an eviction notice Constable's
Devin Northrup and Morgan Russell were
killed in Ontario in October responding
to a disturbance at a home and Constable
Andrew Hong was on a break from training
when he was shot and killed in an ambush
attack in Ontario in September
the Pentagon has released a 43 second
video it says shows the encounter
between a Russian fighter jet and an
American surveillance drone over the
Black Sea the drone's onboard camera
shows the Russian warplane approaching
and then dumping what the Pentagon says
is a plume of fuel on the unmanned drone
it appears the video cuts out briefly
and when it comes back online one of the
drone's propellers is damaged the U.S
calls it an unsafe and unprofessional
Intercept in international airspace
Russia denies it damaged that drone
Poland's President says his country will
send about a dozen fighter jets to
Ukraine becoming the first NATO member
to do so four of the mig-29s will arrive
in the coming days Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski has pleaded for
months for warplanes and this could pave
the way for other countries to follow
suit Slovakia Finland and the
Netherlands have all said they would
consider supplying Ukraine with
warplanes
now to a global news exclusive a
resident of the greater Toronto area is
wanted by American authorities accused
of trying to purchase sensitive
equipment for a tech firm in Tehran that
supports Iran's military experts say the
Iranian regime often uses Canada and
Canadian companies to dodge sanctions
and procure military equipment as Jeff
Semple reports Iran's weapons produced
with North American parts are now being
deployed in Russia's war against Ukraine
foreign
this has become an important part of the
Russian war machine Kamikaze drones made
in Iran
video from Ukrainian police shows
officers shooting down one Iranian drone
but another made it through hitting a
high-rise apartment building in Kiev
killing four people Iranian drones have
bombed Ukraine relentlessly in recent
months capable of striking targets far
from the front lines they are designed
to be used only one time is designed to
inflict the maximum damage Damien
spliter's team of weapons investigators
analyzed the wreckage from Iranian
drones in Ukraine and made a troubling
find we discovered that they were
heavily reliant on on Western components
and Technology he says more than 80
percent of Iranian drone parts were
actually produced by companies in
Western countries including the United
States and Canada
Global News traced one case involving
allegations of trying to send drone Tech
to Iran to this home near Toronto hello
hi oh is Vader here
no who's this Vader faki is facing
federal charges in the United States the
Indian citizen moved to Canada in 2010
and launched his own Consulting business
and tech company
according to the U.S charges between
2017 and 2018 faki and his brother tried
to obtain highly sensitive pieces of
equipment for a Tehran technology
company that supports Iran's military
including counter drone technology and
an industrial microwave system which the
U.S says can be used to create
high-powered energy weapons
faki's brother allegedly requested an
agent fee of 20 000 US dollars for their
help procuring the equipment writing in
an email that the company in Canada is
taking a huge risk refer from global
news we're just hoping to talk to him
foxy wasn't at home and did not respond
to our list of questions eventually
reached by phone he declined to comment
on the advice of his lawyer
the charges against him have not been
proven in court according to this U.S
indictment faki's brother was arrested
by the Americans 18 months ago and has
since pleaded guilty to violating U.S
sanctions against Iran faki is also
wanted by American authorities but he's
been living and working freely here in
Canada and even applied for Canadian
citizenship were you surprised to hear
about a case like this I'm not surprised
I know that people with ties to Iran's
regime operate in Canada last October
the Prime Minister announced what he
called the most robust and comprehensive
sanctions in the world against Iran that
is why today we're using the most
powerful tools at our disposal to crack
down on this brutal regime Banning
thousands of regime members from
entering Canada and restricting
Financial transactions there seems to be
a real mismatch between the government's
rhetoric and its actions a Canada Border
Services spokesperson said dozens of
people with it ties to the regime and
its revolutionary guard the irgc had
been denied entry to Canada but none had
been deported we're not seeing any
movement on the reports we've made
um in the sort of identifying irgc
members this Refugee lawyer and activist
says police lack resources ottawa's
announcement last year included 76
million dollars for sanctions
enforcement but the RCMP says it hasn't
yet received the funds the irgc has been
circumventing International laws for
decades they've become good at it
they're able to
operate through proxies in Focus case
U.S prosecutors say Iran tried to evade
sanctions by sending the money first to
Dubai then to faki's Canadian company
Foci allegedly purchased the equipment
for Iran from a company in Massachusetts
and tried to export it to Dubai but the
shipment was intercepted by U.S
authorities
Iran's weapons support for Russia in
Ukraine is made possible by its ability
to evade Western sanctions adding
urgency to calls for Canada and others
to crack down Jeff sempel Global News
Toronto
a new twist in the rattled banking
sector 11 of America's biggest banks
have agreed to prop up another
struggling Bank First Republic by
depositing 30 million dollars into it
it's meant not just to stabilize First
Republic but to send a message to
depositors in global markets that
America's banking system is secure and
gaviola looks at how Canadian banks are
positioned to handle all this turmoil
this week the government took decisive
and forceful actions to stabilize and
strengthen public confidence in our
financial system in Washington more
reassurances that America's banking
system is sound deeply important when it
comes to the financial system it falls
apart if people don't have faith in it
it's not about econometrics or macro or
microeconomics it's about consumer
psychology we saw hints of that this
week with two runs on Regional U.S banks
and investors rocked by concerns about
the viability of long-troubled Credit
Suisse Wednesday sending its stock to
record lows Switzerland's Central Bank
stepped in with a 74 billion dollar loan
Credit Suisse has a lot of links to
um the financial sectors of other
countries
says it has operations in the U.S in
other parts of Europe and more widely
around the world so it's these it's the
global links which are the real concern
these Extreme Measures are working so
far U.S President Joe Biden has pledged
tougher banking regulation and the
American Central Bank is guaranteeing
deposits at all banks we're already
seeing the contagion uh dying down in
the states it may take another couple of
days markets do overshoot from time to
time and I think we have seen the
markets overshoot investors are waiting
to see where the next signs of Crisis
will flare up on the heels of this
week's warnings from credit ratings
agency Moody's about more pain ahead for
the U.S banking system and even though
Canadian banks are well funded
Diversified and more stringently
regulated a financial disaster in
another country can spread here during
the 2009 financial crisis Canadian Banks
were really quite well insulated from
what was going on globally yet we still
felt the ramifications of a financial
crisis globally when you have a fear of
the the entire system coming down that's
in a completely different category I
mean that that's that's catastrophic the
financial system is strengthened by
confidence weakened by fear and gaviola
Global News Toronto
with all the allegations of
state-sponsored interference by China so
much attention is focused on what's
happening right now well it's worth
noting that 100 years ago the Canadian
government passed the Chinese Exclusion
Act Banning the entry of virtually all
Chinese immigrants for 24 years as David
Aiken reports one Senator is worried a
proposed foreign agent registry could be
the modern version of that law in a word
there are three it was the liberal
government of William Lyon Mackenzie
King that passed what became known as
the Chinese Exclusion Act an act that
came into force on July the 1st
1923. many Chinese took to calling the
1st of July humiliation day the law
banned any Chinese person from coming
into Canada and required all Chinese
people already in the country to
register with the federal government or
face fines jail or even deportation
the Chinese Immigration Act or better
known as the Chinese Exclusion Act of
1923 had a dramatic and devastating
impact on Chinese immigrants and their
communities inside and outside of Canada
that law would stay on the books for 24
years until 1947. even then Canada put
restrictions on immigration from China
restrictions not fully removed until
1967.
Senator Juan Paul Wu worries that a
foreign agent registry proposed last
week by the Trudeau government will set
up a new foreign influenced transparency
registry in Canada could be a modern
version of that Exclusion Act I would
like to think that even Advocates of a
registry would agree with me that it
should not be one that stigmatizes or
alienates any particular Community
Minister medicino the government is
taking advice until May the 9th on how
best to create such a registry we may
need new laws to deal with covert to
deal with coercive and corrupt
activities and the registry May well
help us in that direction for its part
the Trudeau government says it is
sensitive to the idea that a foreign
agent registry might be seen to be
targeting or stigmatizing a particular
ethnic Community but the Prime Minister
and his cabinet also feel that a
registry of those paid by Foreign
governments is an important tool to
combat interference in Canada's Affairs
Donna okay David Aiken in snowy Ottawa
thanks Canada is lifting its covid-19
testing requirement for Air travelers
from China Hong Kong and Macau starting
first thing tomorrow morning there will
no longer be any federal coveted
measures in place the government says it
has not detected any new variants of
concern and the situation has improved
in both Canada and China
political leaders visit amqui Quebec
coming up the premier's pledge after
this week's deadly incident
at least one person is missing after a
501 fire tours through a Heritage
building in Old Montreal early this
morning people living in the building
could be heard shouting for help at
least one person jumped from a window
nine people were taken to the hospital
suffering Burns and smoke inhalation
some of the units were being used as
Airbnb rentals and it's feared other
people could be missing
Quebec's Premier went to the small town
of amqui today to offer condolences
Francois Lago was joined by provincial
opposition leaders he promised to boost
Mental Health Services across Quebec a
Monday a Mander of a pickup truck into
pedestrians killing two people and
injuring nine others 38 year old Steve
Gagnon has been charged with two counts
of dangerous driving causing death and
more charges could be laid
ultimatum ahead why the U.S is
threatening to permanently ban tick-tock
[Music]
the UK followed Canada and other allies
today becoming the latest country to ban
Tick Tock from all government devices
because of National Security concerns
now the U.S is raising the stakes as
Jackson prosco reports Washington is
demanding tick tock's Chinese parent
company sell its stake in the app or it
will be banned in the U.S
the clock is ticking for tick tock after
a sharp ultimatum from Washington that
could see the platform completely banned
in the U.S we have concerns as we have
said many times before about this
particular software the Biden
Administration is demanding tick tock's
Chinese parent company bite dance sell
off the app increasingly the US and its
allies view Tick-Tock as a security
threat in part because of China's
national security laws that give Beijing
access to data from Chinese companies
this is essentially an opening Salvo to
perhaps try to enhance the overall
protections against that in a statement
a tick tock spokesperson told Global
News if protecting National Security is
the objective divestment doesn't solve
the problem a change in ownership would
not impose any new restrictions on data
flows or access they argue that in their
U.S operations they don't share any data
with the Chinese government they also
note that they comply with Chinese laws
those two things can't necessarily exist
together
China's foreign Ministry said the U.S
has failed to provide evidence that Tick
Tock threatens National Security we
always have that dilemma in the west
don't we we believe in free speech and
free competition in the marketplace and
yet we don't want our data to be scooped
up and used for nefarious purposes
concern extends far beyond Washington
Canadian officials refuse to comment on
whether tick tock's ownership is
currently under National Security review
Ottawa recently banned the app from
government devices the UK did the same
Thursday
it is both prudent and proportionate to
restrict the use of certain apps
concerns about Tick Tock run much deeper
than just data there are more than 100
million users in the us alone and
increasingly control of the platform is
seen as vital to controlling the flow of
information and disinformation
Jackson prosco Global News Washington in
tonight's Syria Canada is Athen Ontario
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching our announcer will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and I will see you
Saturday for the new reality bye-bye
foreign
[Music]